en este vídeo quiero resolver algunos
problemas que utilizan el teorema de la
bisectriz vamos a empezar con esta
figura aquí queremos determinar la
longitud de este cachito x y sabemos que
este lado mide 3 este lado mide 6 y este
cachito de aquí mide 2 y además esta
recta morada es una bisectriz porque
estos dos ángulos están marcados como
iguales de esta forma podemos aplicar el
teorema de la bisectriz para concluir
que 3 entre 2 3 entre 2 es igual a 6
entre x es igual a 6 entre x y con esta
igualdad podemos determinar el valor de
x por ejemplo podemos multiplicar
cruzado la x para acá el 2 para acá nos
quedaría 3 x es igual a 12 y dividiendo
entre 3 de ambos lados nos queda que x
es igual a 4 entonces esta x vale 4 este
x es igual a 4 y entonces sucede algo
interesante porque entonces todo este
lado de acá mide 24 o sea mide 6 y como
éste ya sabemos que mide 6 entonces
podemos concluir que este triángulo es
isósceles eso me parece algo pues muy
interesante
ahora vayamos a este triángulo de aquí
abajo el triángulo verde
ahora tenemos que este lado mide 5 este
lado mide 7 todo este lado mide 10 otra
vez esta línea azul es una bisectriz
porque estos dos ángulos están marcados
como iguales y lo que queremos en esta
figura es determinar el valor de x pero
existe es nada más este cachito digamos
d
ab vale de esta a esta vez bueno una vez
más vamos a utilizar el teorema de la
bisectriz entonces tenemos que 5 / x 5 /
x esta razón es igual a 7 entre este
segmento de acá es igual a 7 entre y
este segmento este segmento pues cuánto
mide todo mide x
perdón todo mide 10 este cachito mide x
y por lo tanto este segmento de acá me
de 10 - x vale entonces es 7 / 10 - x
aquí podemos multiplicar cruzado nos
queda 50 menos 5 x es igual a 7 x
podemos sumar 5 x de ambos lados nos
queda que 50 es igual a 12 x y ahora
dividiendo entre 12 de los dos lados
tenemos que 50 entre 12 50 entre 12 es
igual a x con esto ya tenemos el valor
de x pero déjame simplificar un poco la
fracción esto es lo mismo que 25 entre 6
25 entre 6
para que se vea más bonito lo voy a
poner como número mixto entonces 6 cabe
cuatro veces en 25 y 6 por 4 24 para 25
sobra uno entonces sería cuatro con un
sexto entonces esta longitud de acá a la
longitud x es cuatro con un sexto cuatro
con un sexto y bueno aunque no nos lo
pidan voy a encontrar esta de acá sería
10 menos 4 con un sexto sería igual a 5
con 5 sextos